québec avait déjà annoncé son intention
de réglementer la cigarette électronique
comme le tabac d'interdire de fumer sur
les terrasses et dans une voiture en
présence de mineurs et de mettre fin à
la vente de tabac aromatisés voilà que
le gouvernement veut aller encore plus
loin il veut appliquer l'interdiction
aux terrains de jeux destinés aux
enfants y compris les aires de jeux
d'eau et les parc de planche à roulettes
cela vaudrait aussi pour la cigarette
électronique et neuf mètres autour de
terrain de jeu qu'on fasse en sorte
qu'un ipod fumée du tout pour ne pas
donner cette image nos enfants puis
québec propose aussi de forcer les
hôpitaux et les établissements hôteliers
a diminué de moitié les chambres où
l'espace réservé aux fumeurs
il passait de 40 à 20% la ministre
souhaite également étendre
l'interdiction de fumer déjà en vigueur
dans les cégeps et universités aux
institutions privées comme l'école du
barreau très bonne nouvelle
le projet de loi devient donc de plus en
plus ambitieux les groupes anti tabac se
réjouissent la ministre dit que le
qu'elle va porter sa réflexion un peu
plus loin dont on est très confiants par
rapport à ce projet doit c'est bien dit
l'opposition officielle mais le projet
de loi pourrait encore être bonifié
comme l'australie l'a fait québec
pourraient notamment imposer l'emballage
neutre qui force les compagnies de tabac
à éliminer leur logo du paquet de
cigarettes et à le rendre moins
attractifs via un amendement sur la
taille des mises en garde mais ça ne
suffit pas on le sait que ça marche
l'emballage neutre
la même façon nous on dit ça prend un
moratoire pour les nouveaux produits de
tabac
gillis est un projet de loi qui fait
quand même pas mal consensus ce qui est
assez rare à l'assemblée nationale oui
bien traditionnellement on est habitués
ici à l'assemblée nationale que
lorsqu'un projet de loi est déposé ça
suscite de longs débats je vous donne un
exemple le projet de loi evin qui
pourrait être adoptée la semaine
prochaine
c'est un projet de loi qui a suscité 160
heures de débats ce fameux projet de loi
sur l'approché à sa cité et le quota de
patients pour les médecins en
comparaison le projet de loi dont on
parle aujourd'hui a commencé à être
étudié ce matin et déjà on est passé à
travers une
zen d'amendements sa céline c'est hocine
qui a une volonté de collaboration entre
les parties si bien que tant
l'opposition que le gouvernement sont
d'accord pour dire qu'on pourrait
adopter ce projet de loi d'ici les fêtes
voilà merci beaucoup julie je vous en
prie au revoir